[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
consacrée aujourd'hui un trafic
d'enfants adoptés les bébés volés du
guatemala un trafic qui a duré plusieurs
décennies sur fond de pouvoir militaire
corrompu et de guerre civile est avec
nous pour en parler carmen maria vega
bonjour carmen vous êtes chanteuse vous
êtes comédienne également auteur d'un
livre qui s'appelle le champ du boult qu
aux éditions flammarion
vous racontez vos péripéties au
guatemala car vous avez été volé un
victimes d'un trafic d'enfants et puis
un jour vous avez décidé de retrouver
vos origines
nous sommes également avec colleen fanon
vous êtes belge adopté par une famille
belge mais en réalité vous aussi avait
été volée à votre mère et vous avez créé
une association racines perdu pour aider
d'autres enfants volés du guatemala car
il y en a des milliers à retrouver leurs
origines
mais commençons par vous carmen donc
vous êtes né en juillet 1984 au
guatemala dans la capitale et puis à
neuf mois vous avez été adopté par une
famille française une famille de
lyonnais via une association belge
vous saviez très peu de choses sur votre
mère injuste qu'elle était activistes
qu'elle vous avez probablement abandonné
et puis un jour le destin a placé pousse
sur votre route un homme providentiel
un homme qui se chargeait de reconnecter
en quelque sorte les guatémaltèques
d'origine à leur pays
et puis vous là vous lui avez demandé
quelque chose oui il s'appelle vincent
simon c'est le porte parole français de
rigoberta menchu quel prix nobel de la
paix en 92 qui se bat pour le droit des
indigènes
il est effectivement son but c'était
juste de me demander si je connaissais
rigoberta si je connaissais mon pays
et moi j'ai vu l'opportunité de lui
demander si m'aiderait à retrouver ma
mère biologique et
je m'attendais pas à ce qu'ils me
répondent oui donc ça c'est assez
bousculé parce que c'était en octobre
9 ou 10 je sais plus et je suis partie
au guatemala 3 mois après donc ça a été
un peu une espèce de
et c'est très bien que ça se soit passé
comme ça dans l'urgence parce que ça m'a
pas j'ai pas eu le temps de réfléchir
trop parce que je connaissais rien de
mon pays d'origine
au moment où j part je connaissais que
la phase jolie delà du tourisme qu'on
nous vendait déjà à l'époque mais
j'ignorais absolument tout du conflit
armé j'en connaissais très peu très peu
de choses sur les années 80 et on
trouvait rien sur internet à ce moment
là sur la situation politique du pays
si j'avais su la situation je suis pas
sûr que je serais parti
en tout cas vous voilà au guatemala à
qui vous vous êtes adressé sur le
terrain alors vincent connaît
extrêmement bien le pays donc ça a été
vraiment mon ange gardien c'est lui qui
connaissait toute l'administration
guatémaltèque qui savait qu'il fallait
aller à l'aréna qui est donc que
l'équivalent de nos mairies pour
demander l'acte de naissance de ma mère
biologique et vérifier s'il y avait des
adresses et on a parcouru le pays comme
ça et très vite je me suis rendu compte
que ça allait être régulier qu'il
fallait pas trop s'enflammer sur des
contres ouvert une adresse
parce que souvent elles étaient fausses
et déjà ça commence à me mettre la puce
à l'oreille je comprenais pas pourquoi
les adresses devait être faux seins et
parce que pour vous vous étiez adopté de
manière tout à fait banal tout est légal
voilà d'où les papiers le sens le
sembler et puis et puis la version de
cette mère biologique activistes dans
les années 80 elle compte complètement
propre possible enfin voilà nous c'est
ce qu'on nous avait dit que c'était la
raison pour laquelle elle me faisait
adopter pour me sauver la vie donc c'est
idéal enfin quand on vous grandit c'est
comme ça avec le fantasme d'une mère
héros qui se bat contre la dictature
sa forme est une femme vous avez été
donc misé sur la piste de votre
grand-père maternel coréen s'est passée
cette rencontre je le retrouve après 13
jours d'investigations à la frontière du
guatemala à skis pulas ça c'est une la
ville où était née ma mère biologique où
j'ai trouvé la dernière clé pour pouvoir
mam a mené au honduras pour rencontrer
ce grand père maternel qui lui me dit
qu'il n'a pas revu ma mère depuis les
années 80 qu'il se rappelle très bien
m'avoir rencontré au moment où je venais
de naître et que j'avais un grand frère
ou une grande soeur il se rappelait pas
exactement
si c'est un grand frère ou une grande
soeur mais que ma mère était assez fâché
après lui et qu'il n'avait pas de
nouvelles et que la seule personne qui
était encore en lien avec elle et m
attendre blanca qui vivait à houston
parce que tout à toute première fratrie
dont appartient à ma mère donc le
premier mariage de mon grand père
on était séparés durant le conflit après
des violences militaires qu'il a subie
par an comment dire ils ont voulu
réquisitionner sa boucherie il sait il
n'a pas voulu obtempérer ce qui était
une erreur il était passé à tabac est
obligé de fuir au honduras en laissant
tous ses enfants et sa femme est ce
qu'il pourra se frotter mona et un an
plus tard il retrouve sa famille qui lui
donne enfin sa femme en l'occurrence qui
lui demande de revenir avec ses enfants
et lui il la trouve enceinte
au bout d'un an et comprend bien qu'elle
n'est pas enceinte de lui il dit ok
condition que que tu te débarrasses de
sept enfants et quelques jours plus tard
elle décède et les gens se retrouvent
orphelins
donc je comprends que je fais partie
d'un pan entier dans le fonds a
abandonné
il est tout blanc le cas a été adopté
par un couple d'américains qui passait
par là
donc si finalement très éclaté a
complètement éclaté vous avez ressenti
quoi en rencontrant votre grand-père bas
c'était le premier maillon et c'était au
bout de treize jours vraiment épuisant
d'émotionnel mans donc c'était
extrêmement bouleversant parce que lui
en plus bas c'était entre guillemets
marrant parce que trois mois avant une
de ses filles donc de cette première
fratrie revient quarante ans après pour
voir son père parce qu'elle avait besoin
de mettre un visage sur ce père qui
l'avait abandonné donc finalement elle
avait l'habitude que déjà on rentre chez
lui pour lui sur le passé de cette
famille donc je suis à la fois ému et
jeu complètement anesthésié d'émotion
aussi parce que je commence à voir
l'arbre qui cache la forêt quoi c'est à
dire que je sens que c'est adobuzz
adoption n'est pas totalement légale
quoi alors donc comment vos après vous
êtes parvenus jusqu'à votre mère passé
laptop blanca qui en l'occurrence donc
que j'appelle à houston qui me met en
relation avec elle
et donc je découvre qu'elle est à
charleroi en belgique donc juste à côté
de vous voilà deux heures trente de
thalys c'est quand même c'est dommage je
trouve en fait 8000 kilomètres pour la
retrouver à côté de soi mais donc là
encore on le sait encore plus
d'incompréhension parce que je me dis
mais alors qu'est ce qu'elle fait en
belgique
ça veut dire que nous a amenés
et puis pourquoi ce frère n'a pas été
signalée mes parents adoptifs c'est très
étrange donc je parle a rencontré 15
jours après être entrés du guatemala
j'étais pas mûre pour y aller
directement en rentrant il fallait aussi
que je parle à mes parents et je leur
explique mes découvertes parce que
fallait il est préparé parce que moi je
sentais que c'était très louche et je
savais qu'il n'était pas responsable et
qu'ils étaient victimes
ausy de ce rappelant sa fille ça arrive
souvent colline fans ont d'ailleurs que
les parents justement qui ont adopté des
enfants voler ils ignorent tout du du
vol 1 oui tout à fait la majorité la
majorité parce que les papiers sont
vraies enfin ce sont des faux mais avec
des données inventé mais les papiers
sont légalement vrai et la trame d'un
dossier paraît plausible et donc les
parents occidentaux toute bonne foi ont
cru à adopter des enfants qui étaient
démunis ou pour les parents avaient des
problèmes c'était faux tout est fait et
donc une fois que vous avez parlé à
votre mère carmen maria vega qu'est ce
qui s'est passé qu'est ce qu'elle vous a
annoncé à prix bas j'ai compris assez
vite qu'elle n'était pas activiste donc
que je vais demander si elle est activée
déjà même pas tellement connaissance de
ce que ça voulait dire activistes donc
je vais demander si les sept battait
contre l'aide la guérilla contre le
pouvoir en place contre la dictature du
tout cas une citoyenne lambda
elle m'explique que mon père
avait émigré à san francisco en lui
promettant de nous faire venir une fois
qu'ils trouveraient du travail donc les
trois premiers mois elle a envoyé de
l'argent pour quelle qu'elle puisse
survivre
et bien moi la disparue l'a plus jamais
rien d'envoyer donc elle s'est retrouvée
mère célibataire dans cette capitale du
guatemala dont elles n'étaient pas
originaires
vous n'avez plus de famille ni mère ni
père et quelques amis mais dans des t2
qui vivait un peu les mêmes histoires
donc pour faire garder ses enfants pour
pouvoir avoir de l'argent pour pouvoir
travailler
donc faut avoir une nourrice c'était un
cercle vicieux donc là elle rencontre
elle va voir les soeurs qui la met en
relation avec une certaine ophelia des
gammes à ce qui aide les femmes
célibataires sur le plus justement un
nom un nom qui fait déjà bien sûr c'est
une femme qui était finalement à
l'origine de ce trafic d'enfants est ce
que peux nous en parler colline de cette
femme
oui tout à fait donc ophelia des gamma
c'était la belle-soeur du dictateur à
l'époque en place oscar arias victor
hesse elle est arrêtée une première fois
début des années 80 avec edmond mulet
qui a été sacré deuxième secrétaire de
l'onu pendant plusieurs années elle est
arrêté une seconde fois en 1987 pour
trafic d'enfants est là avec des enfants
destination de la belgique et la france
est donc vraiment c'était orchestrée au
plus haut niveau en fait ce trafic
d'enfants donc vous avez été d'ailleurs
toutes deux victimes vous nous emparer
tout à l'heure mais donc elle elle vous
explique tout votre mère palm excuses
elle m'explique ce qu'elle sait quoi ça
sert quels soient pas grand chose en
plus c'est long plus c'est à dire que
avant noël et on lui a promis on lui a
juste promis que c'était un placement
temporaire que oui bien sûr si elle
voulait quitter le pays parce qu'elle
s'était son ce qu'elle leur avait
demandé ces je veux juste quitté ce pays
donc si vous me parlez de la belgique
moi je connais pas d'accord je veux bien
les accompagner donc pour les placer
temporairement dans des familles
d'accueil
c'est ça qu'on lui avait promis et une
fois que j'aurai trouvé un travail une
maison je les récupère mais bien sûr
mais pas de problème sauf que quand elle
arrive sur le sol belge elle comprend
assez rapidement que c'est pas si simple
que ça on lui arrache et mon frère qui
s'accroche à sa jambe et moi qui ai
fille dans ses bras dont canal mille
temps de nous dire au revoir dans le
même temps elle me voit partir derrière
une vitre sans teint hâlé dans les bras
de mes parents adoptifs qui n'ont pas du
tout connaissance de la présence de ma
mère biologique dans l'aéroport et les
parents de mon frère ou biologie qui
rencontrent donc ces nouveaux parents à
qui on dit que la femme en question est
une accompagnante on ne dit pas on ne
leur a pas dit que c'était ma mère notre
mère donc il ya la faune
maintenant ils ont il se demande
effectivement pourquoi qu'il y avait
autant d'émotion dans ses adieux qui
comprennent mieux quoi mais donc là elle
terrible et vous savez quoi d'apprendre
tout ça bah moi c'est que c'est
complètement
c'est une espèce de vague de c'est
beaucoup trop pour moi ce moment là
parce que je me dis est d'accord en fait
donc là je découvre une vérité et une
meilleure complètement aimante qui
retrouve un bébé est qui qui me submerge
d'amour et j'ai pas les clés à ce moment
là quoi et en plus j'ai des parents
adoptifs à ce moment là qu'ils sont
complètement paniquée de de ce que je
suis en train de découvrir et
et moi je fais tampon entre tout le
monde en essayant de faire en sorte
qu'ils comprennent que je ne les accuse
de rien j'ai compris qu'ils étaient
victimes et ge et ça ça a été très long
pour admettre ça on a mis bien trois ans
avant de arriver à se comprendre sur les
besoins des uns et des autres moi
j'avais besoin qu'ils acceptent que ce
trafic là ils s'en sont victimes au même
titre que moi et que ma mère biologique
une triangulaire c'est il ya personne
qui est coupable
à part les gens qui les ont manipulés on
va faire une courte pause et on se
retrouve juste après pour la suite de la
grande interview de retour dans la
grande interview pour évoquer la
question du trafic d'enfants des bébés
guatémaltèque nous sommes avec carmen
maria vega et coline fans ont tout deux
qui ont été des enfants volés à leur
famille pour être adoptés par des
familles occidentales alors vous colle
une fan ont même chose vous avez a été
arraché à votre mère quelques heures
après votre naissance
est-ce que vous pouvez nous nous
expliquer en quoi consistait ce trafic
d'enfants qui a duré plusieurs décennies
oui donc en fait c'est une association
belge qui s'appelle a serpenté qui
proposait de par l'intermédiaire de fait
les dégâts masse au guatemala des
enfants à l'adoption à des parents
belges et français mais également
hollandais
on l'a appris il ya peu est donc cette
organisation se charger de la partie
administrative en europe et envoyer les
dossiers au guatemala et ça va concerner
combien d'enfants
les chiffres exacts ne sont pas très
clair mais plusieurs centaines et en
sachant que c'est l'association sérénité
qui faisait les trajets avec les enfants
depuis le guatemala jusqu'en belgique
n'avait pas qu'une seule association y
avait une seule ou plusieurs
associations qui s'occupait de ce trafic
d'enfants finalement il y avait une
seule association avec plusieurs
personnes
personne et comment ça s'est déroulé sur
combien de temps donc les adoptions
commencé au début des années 80 jusqu'au
officiellement début des années 90 mais
à des enfants qui ont été adoptées par
après mais de manière tout à fait
illégale qui était au courant de ce
trafic d'enfants parce que les familles
occidentales ne l'était pas mais est ce
que au guatemala et dans l'association
on savait pertinemment
il y avait un trafic d'enfants a
orchestré alors il faut toujours bien
respecter la présomption d'innocence et
une procédure judiciaire qui est en
cours donc on ne peut pas dire que les
gens sont coupable ou pas coupable ils
sont présumés suspects au jour
d'aujourd'hui au guatemala évidemment ça
s'est joué à tous les niveaux de pouvoir
au plus haut jusqu'au plus bas de saint
du simple officier de l'état civil qui
falsifié un document jusqu'au directeur
général de l'immigration qui était le
beau fils de fela dégâts masse pour
faire signer les passeports et faire
sortir les enfants du pays
mais là c'est très étonnant c'est que
c'est carrément jusqu'au plus haut
sommet de l'état guatémaltèque a fait
ouais tout à fait
enfin il ya des gars masse elle a été
inculpée au guatemala oui oui et donc
comment ça se passe et quels types de
mères étaient concernés mais toutes les
mères en fait avec les au jour
d'aujourd'hui on se rend compte que
toutes les mères étaient concernés des
mers pauvres des mère analphabète mère
handicapée des mers prostituées mais ça
allait aussi à des plus haut niveau avec
des familles tout à fait banale est
normal et donc vous vous occupez
aujourd'hui parce que vous avez connu ça
vous dire comment vous avez découvert qu
on ne vous avait arraché à votre mère
carmen par quart d'heure
j'ai toujours tendance à dire que c'est
la plus grosse claque de ma vie mais
voilà par carmen qui n'était pas au
courant quand je les contacte et qu'ils
n'étaient pas au courant que je n'étais
pas au courant et donc qui m'a expliqué
cette vérité qui m'a qui m'a détruite
autant qu'elle m'a poussé à continuer et
qui m'a poussé à retrouver ma mère
finalement qui vivait ou au guatemala
guatemala est donc aujourd'hui vous
voyez votre famille d'origine
oui oui alors vous avez décidé de monter
cette association pour aider les
personnes qui sont dans le même cas que
vous à retrouver leur famille d'origine
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
comment ça fonctionne comment vous
retrouver ces personnes comment voulait
sensibiliser comment vous les aider
alors dans un premier temps nous ne
retrouve les gens viennent à nous pour
nous demander une première lecture donc
on fait une lecture du dossier
au niveau de la chronologie au niveau
des évidemment des noms ce reviennent
régulièrement des noms d'avocats des
noms des noms de personnes signataires
de personnes signataires qui ont été
arrêtés à guatemala donc on a aussi une
liste donnée on peut avoir des
références
une fois que tout ça est fait on fait
appel à des archivistes en généalogie
qui font des recherches dans les
registres digitaux et puis on travaille
avec plusieurs associations au guatemala
dont la plus importante est notre
partenaire premier qui est la liga qui
est qu'il ya un programme de recherche
pour les personnes disparues et qui
recherchent les enfants disparus du
guatemala il faut aussi signaler que ce
trafic était très lucrative pour les
personnes qu'ils organisaient combien ça
rapporte et d'argent à ces trafiquants
alors en termes de trafic au guatemala
on parle de 200 millions de dollars par
an et en termes d'adoption pour les
adoptions européennes ont parlé
les tarifs varient entre 5000 dollars de
l'époque jusqu'à 15000 dollars par
enfant et les parents payer cette somme
mais il savait
à quoi était destinée de l'argent pas
non non c'était forfaitaire ça se
faisait en 2022 mensualités de ça se
faisait en deux parties il n'y avait pas
de décompte spécifique par rapport au
montant si ce n'est pour couvrir les
frais d'avocats les frais de traduction
les frais de justice parce que tous les
actes d'adoption était légalisé au
guatemala falsifiés mais égaliser et à
ce que les parents occidentaux sont
surpris enfin j'imagine on est très
choquée par de découvrir finalement
qu'ils ont été une partie importante
d'un trafic à la majorité des parents
sont dans un premier temps triste triste
d'accompagner leurs enfants dans cette
dans cette recherche identitaire et puis
se retrouver face à cette vérité qui est
qui et qui est détruit elle détruit tout
le monde et il faut comme carmen le
souligner il faut se relever et ça prend
du temps
donc vous vous aider donc ces enfants il
ya aussi tout un volet politique vous
allez rencontrer des décideurs des
associations pour essayer de faire
connaître l'histoire de ce trafic
d'enfants comment vous procédé en
multipliant les contacts donc on a des
contacts on a eu l'honneur de pouvoir
rencontrer le procureur des droits de
l'homme au guatemala qui nous encourage
tous ici en europe à faire connaître ce
qui s'est passé à prendre contact avec
les associations au guatemala il ya
énormément de gens qui militent au
guatemala pour retrouver les enfants
disparus parce qu'on parle quand même de
5000 à 8000 enfants
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya 5000 entre
5000 et 8000 maman et familles qui
cherchent leurs disparus et est ce que
c'est un dossier brûlant justement
guatemala est ce que vous êtes aidez
parce que notamment dans les années 2000
une activiste maria gutiérrez qui
enquêtait sur ce problème à des enfants
volés a tout bonnement disparu elle est
probablement morte hélas pour maman
blanc était assassiné est-ce que c'est
dangereux de faire parler d'eux autour
de cette cause alors il faut quand même
être prudent
notre liberté de parole en europe est
tout à fait différente on ne tient pas
le même discours au guatemala ça c'est
sûr et certain
après il faut en parler les faits sont
ce qu'ils sont nous sommes la preuve
vivante que ça existait donc il faut en
parler il ya une procédure judiciaire en
belgique
elle en est où et c'était aussi une
enquête en france alors il ya une
procédure judiciaire en belgique qui est
diligentée par le parquet fédéral
elle est en cours d'instruction donc
d'où le secret d'instruction donc on ne
peut absolument rien dire on espère
avoir des réponses
une mise en lumière sur les
responsabilités ou les non
responsabilité des personnes qui ont
péri ces adoptions l heure en france pas
ma connaissance non non et vous car même
quand vous êtes allés au guatemala pour
rechercher votre famille d'origine est
ce que vous avez eu peur oui extrêmement
parce que j'arrive dans un pays qui
n'ait causé par la violence
et beaucoup plus qu'en temps de guerre
en fait quand jan 2010 le guatemala a le
triste record de 18 morts par balles par
jour qui sont des homicides volontaires
et qui sont souvent dues aux
narcotrafiquants et une théorisation du
peuple qui a été mis en place par l'état
mais même à ce moment là l'état étaient
dépassés par l'ampleur de ces violences
et il règne dans la dans la capitale à
ce moment là une tension palpable où on
sent qu'il est qu il est complètement
possible de se prendre une balle perdue
à tout moment quoi selon vous deux
comment ça a pu se produire un tel
trafic sans que ce soit a dénoncé fin
d'ailleurs ça a été dénoncé un délai le
début des années 80 mais finalement le
trafic a persisté
qu'est-ce qui n'a pas fonctionné la
corruption a tout simplement oui la
corruption guatemala c'est le sport
national
donc c'est facile d'étouffer jeudi
reflets des gamins ça a été condamné
mais derrière n'a jamais purgé sa peine
il ya une annulation de 2
de sa peine elle a été libérée ce
précieux belle expression et quand
est-ce que ça s'est arrêté justement ce
trafic d'enfants de guatemala on sait
pas le dire on sait pas le dire parce
qu'encore au jour d'aujourd'hui donc les
derniers enfants adoptés sont arrivés en
2007 donc ils sont âgés de 13 ans gens
d'aujourd'hui les parents adoptants
passé parfois directement avec les
personnes de contact que nous on avait à
l'époque dans les années 80 au guatemala
et donc on ne peut pas dire au jour
d'aujourd'hui que ça s'est arrêté par
les adoptions ne sont plus depuis 2007
ne peux pas dire quand ça s'est arrêté
donc 2057 ya encore des enfants qui ont
été volés en 2007 qui sont susceptibles
d'avoir été volés oui tout à fait vrai
et alors aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres trafics d'enfants au guatemala
a priori ça s'arrêtait mais ce qu il yad
autres trafics d'enfants dans le monde
toutes les guerres à son à son lot de
trafic d'humains je veux dire on en
reparle dans quelques années avec la
syrie les gens qui arrivent sur nos
plages je déclare un passeur pour
essayer d'utiliser la détresse de
quelqu'un c'est un trafic d'humains donc
il n'ya pas de guerre sans trafic
d'humains et vous colline femmes où vous
avez vent de certains trafics d'enfants
aujourd'hui dans d'autres pays que le
guatemala
oui tout à fait donc le parquet fédéral
belge enquête également sur sur un
trafic d'enfants de du congo nous
d'enfants d'adoption qui se sont
déroulées au congo vers la belgique et à
quelle période 2016-2020 tout à fait
récent par qui ont été adoptés ces
enfants d'ailleurs parce qu'il ya cette
association belge mais les enfants
étaient répartis sur toute la planète
donc les oui oui ça s'est réparti entre
la france la belgique et la hollande
mais on retrouve des liens avec le
canada les états-unis israël italie l
espagne donc oui tout le monde est
concerné est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous à
titre personnel tout deux vous êtes
toujours pour l'adoption ou ça vous fait
jeter un regard particulier sur ce
processus
moi je suis évidemment toujours pour ces
jeux
j'ai par ronnie l'amour j'ai reçu mes
parents adoptifs
il ya des gens qui ne peuvent pas avoir
d'enfant ne serait ce que parce qu'ils
sont stériles pour les couples gays
aussi donc je serai toujours pour mais
je mettrais toujours en garde peu
importe les couples hétéro ou gay ou peu
importe femmes célibataires père
célibataire voulant adopter sur les
conditions il faut être très vigilant et
à l'international c'est toujours
compliqué vire les règles sont
différentes dans chaque pays et faire
toujours attention quand c'est des pays
en guerre parce que c'est on est la
preuve que que c'est facile de falsifier
des choses donc je ne vais jamais dira
non un orphelin n'a pas le droit d'avoir
des parents au contraire mais s'il n'a
vraiment pas de plus par an s'il est
vraiment faire mais alors quels sont vos
préconisations par exemple colline fanon
pour des personnes qui souhaitent
adopter aujourd'hui sachant qu'il est
parfois difficile de savoir si l'enfant
issu d'un trafic selon le pays d'origine
donc nous avec racine perdu on a déposé
des conclusions à l'ail
justement avec des demandes de révision
de niveau de la légalisation au niveau
des preuves adn au jour d'aujourd'hui on
a cette magnifique science qui permet de
déterminer si l'enfant est bien l'enfant
delà de la personne qui le met en
adoption donc utilisant les à bon
escient
qu'est ce que aujourd'hui qu'est ce que
vous demanderiez pour ses enfants du
guatemala
quand vous êtes vous fait vos plaidoyer
à l'est ou ailleurs qu'est-ce que vous
demander davantage de de transparence
davantage de contrôles il ya une
première chose que je pense qui est
importante c'est que les états que ce
soit la france ou la belgique
reconnaissent cette situation
reconnaissent qu'il ya eu des adoptions
illégales reconnaissent qui a eu trafic
d'enfants et qu'on met des choses en
place pour pouvoir accompagner et faire
le chemin inverse donc à partir du
moment où un état pose des actes
administratifs avec des fonctionnaires
qui sont assermentés par l'état qu'ils
soient français belges hollandais ou peu
importe l'état est responsable a une
part de responsabilité je ne met pas du
tout en cause la légalité de l'adoption
mais en termes de responsabilité et de
finalement de passation de nationalité
parce qu'on a eu via l'adoption on a cet
extrême chance aussi faut le dire d'être
d'être française ou belge
et je pense que c'est aussi de leur
responsabilité de pouvoir dire au jour
aujourd'hui voilà il s'est passé ça et
vous ô carmen maria vega vous militez
aussi pour qu'il y ait davantage de
transparence et que qu'on aide qu'on
fasse toute la lumière sur ce scandale
ben j'espère du fond du coeur que notre
procédure aboutira qu'un procurant se
passionnera pour notre histoire et il
fera à reconnaître les faits j'avoue
qu'en france je suis complètement seul
dans ce combat là et collines
elle a fait bouger beaucoup de lignes en
belgique et est comme l'association et
belges ça fait plus d'émulation en
belgique
là je suis dans un stade un peu
compliqué parce que je suis artiste j'ai
écrit un livre à ce sujet là j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir une très bonne presse qui
a beaucoup relayé mon histoire et qui me
permet d'être entendu visible et de le
servir cette cause là donc on
militantisme il est ici mais j'avoue
être très seul à dénoncer les choses ici
vous savez qui pourrait encore être
inculpé au guatemala pour ce trafic
d'enfants alors c'est très compliqué de
répondre à cette question pourquoi parce
qu'en terme de l'illégalité c'est un
point qui est important a précisé
la belgique est le premier pays à
soulever les prescriptions donc
normalement sont des faits qui sont
prescrits
la belgique 2 par l'usagé qui est fait
l'identité falsifiés de parle usage
uniquement sur cette base là à lever les
prescriptions au niveau des fai de
d'enlèvement séquestrations escroqueries
à l'adoption organisation criminelle
faux usage de faux et c'est ce qui
permet au parquet fédéral belge de
pouvoir poursuivre cette procédure je
voudrais quand même juste a ajouté que
le procureur fédéral a quand même fait
une petite a fait une interview en
belgique dans laquelle il a expliqué
qu'il lui l'équipe en tout cas la
justice essayerait d'apporter des
réponses aux questions légitimes des
victimes qui sont posées merci beaucoup
coline fanon et carmen maria vega
d'avoir répondu à nos questions donc sur
ce trafic d'enfants volés du guatemala
carmen maria vega je rappelle votre
livre le champ du boult qu aux éditions
flammarion qui raconte votre voyage au
guatemala pour retrouver vos origines
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission sur
rtl france point tva bientôt sur rt
france
[Musique]